so for the first time ever Disney is
going to feature an openly gay character
in a movie the upcoming film titled the
Jungle Cruise which will be based on a
theme park ride presumably a theme park
ride called the Jungle Cruise I don't
know just my deductive reasoning there
and of course all great films had been
based on theme park rides but this one
is being billed as a turning point for
the company and it will be different
from the you might say the more subtle
homosexuality that has appeared in other
Disney movies for instance the recent
Beauty and the Beast remake there was a
great deal made of ahead of time before
the movie came out what was being
marketed we heard a lot about the gay
elements in this movie and that was
supposed to be a turning point this big
deal but in that case it turns out that
it was merely implied that a male
character had an erotic obsession with
another male character which to me
at a minimum seems like an extremely
unnecessary plot point to put into a
children's movie that's just me if I if
I were producing a children's movie
there isn't any point where I would stop
and say now hold on a second everybody
maybe this male character should have an
erotic obsession with that one
maybe we should include that into
because of the children's movie and I
would just think why why do we need
erotic obsessions really of any kind
in a children's movie but that's some
again yes just I guess I don't know
maybe I'm the crazy one now in this case
it will be different it will be made
apparently very clear explicitly so that
the hugely affect character and that's
the quote it's a quote from an article
the character is going to be hugely
affect it will be made clear that he is
gay and that he is not interested in
women and if that is how the film goes
then now when I say it's going to be
made explicitly clear
you
let's hope not too explicit but but I
don't really know where they're going
with this and if that is what happens in
the film if it is to any extent made
clear this okay this is an openly gay
character that it will be a turning
point I think because hugely affect gay
characters are quite common these days
in film and television and it seems like
they include them in every TV show in
every movie that is not for kids but
that's not usually how it goes in Disney
movies it's not usually how it goes in
mainstream family films so this would
represent Disney really crossing a
threshold and entering into a realm that
would have seemed unthinkable and
unbelievable even just 10 years ago
now as you might expect there has been
some blowback over this over this news
but not from religious conservatives
again if this was 10 years ago or 15
years ago 20 years ago 30 years ago
there would have been quite a bit of
blowback from religious conservatives
but but not now the outrage in this case
is coming from the left its liberals who
are upset about this
because we have been told it is quote
problematic that Jack Whitehall the
actor hired to play the gay man is not
himself a gay man and so that's that's a
problem he has been hired to pretend to
be something that he isn't and and that
we were not allowed to do that anymore
now bear this in mind Jack Whitehall is
apparently completely straight he's not
even a little bit gay
so that just that just makes it all the
worse because even if he were a little
bit gay or partially gay somewhat gay
that still would not be good enough
because consider the fact that the
actress Ruby Rose is facing criticism
because of her casting as a lesbian bat
woman there's a there's a bat woman
series coming out on I believe the CW
about a lesbian bat woman now Rose
herself is a lesbian but apparently
she's not lesbian enough I'm not making
this up that that's actually what the
the left is saying that she's getting
criticism from liberals because her
personal lesbianism is not of a kind and
to a degree that would justify casting
her as a lesbian bat woman that's I mean
this is
this is just crazy
and you know what I won't even get into
the blatant double standards here I
won't focus especially on that that's a
different topic but there is obviously a
huge double standard when you whine
about a straight guy being cast as a gag
tech character or even a mostly gay
woman being cast as a completely gay
character when you whine about that yet
yet at the same time you celebrate when
women are cast in traditionally male
roles or when a black person is cast in
a traditionally white role you know or
even when a gay actor is cast in a
straight role and I think it stands to
reason that there have been dozens
hundreds maybe thousands of straight
characters portrayed by gay actors in
Hollywood over you know the course of
Hollywood's history but we're not
allowed to complain about that you could
never complain about that so the left
anytime you've got they do this stupid
stunt where they they take a you know a
male character and they say we're gonna
do this movie again but with women you
know anytime they do that if any man
breathes even a word of criticism or
even rolls their eyes at it the left
will pounce on them to call you sexist
you just hate women look at you when
usually by the way usually when people
complain like if they're doing a female
Ghostbusters type of thing the complaint
there isn't that they're stealing
they're stealing characters from men
it's like no it's just it's just a
stupid childish thing to do like it's
just this really childish mentality of
oh well men had that character now women
have to have it okay everything equal no
go just go make your own characters
that's that's our only place just it's
just a dumb childish thing we're not
that upset about or just rolling our
eyes now in this case there are people
who are really upset about it saying
that it's problematic that Jack
Whitehall is not gay
and
objectively
you know of course objectively all
things being you none none of this
should matter whether you cast women in
male roles gay people are straight
people other way around whatever that
doesn't it doesn't matter because acting
by definition means pretending to be
something you are not
actor must now actually be whatever he
is pretending to be then he's not
pretending anymore and it is no longer
acting
at most what you would have then are
reenactments you would have actors
re-enacting their everyday lives I guess
that's the only kind of movie that's
allowed to be made anymore certainly
we'd have to cease production on all
sci-fi films on all fantasy films on all
historical films you can't very well
have Daniel day-lewis acting like Abe
Lincoln if he isn't Abe Lincoln only
actors who are a blinkin can be Abe
Lincoln so I think it's fair to say to
Daniel day-lewis
are you really a blinkin and of course
we'll give him a chance to respond but
if it turns out that he's not Abe
Lincoln which I think there's at least a
90% chance that he isn't then he has
just committed a great offense against
Abe Lincoln
I think what we're seeing here is is
what happens when identity politics
invades even the fictional realm that's
how bad it's gotten that I guess the
identity the the Warriors for identity
politics they have they have invaded
every realm in the real world and now
they are now they are trying to
commandeer even the fictional realm and
it does to the fictional realm what it
does everywhere else which is it
destroys but I think actually that is um
that's not even the real point here well
that's not the real take away from this
from this whole story the real point the
real takeaway is that leftists are once
again dissatisfied with their own
success
they have been handed another
significant really I would say
incredible cultural victory which is the
injection of explicit homosexuality into
a mainstream family film that really is
a big thing so that is a big deal it's
easy for us to say oh it's just a movie
no this is something as as I said now a
few times this would have been
unthinkable
even race in recent history
um but that's what they've been given
and they still find some ridiculous
pedantic reason to turn up their noses
at it as I wrote yesterday they're like
they're like a football team that wins
seventy two three and then cries after
the game that it was rigged against them
because the other team managed to put up
a field goal that's that's what it feels
like and on the other hand
as you think about how the left has
reacted being given this huge victory
but it's not enough they've been given
almost everything it's not enough they
want more they're always they're always
looking you can seed all the ground in
the world to them but then they're gonna
look at that little little sliver of
ground then you have not yet seeded and
they're gonna say I want that too
I won't be satisfied with all this until
I have that as well that's what I want
so they're always looking to conquer the
next thing compare that
to cultural conservatives now I'm
speaking now about cultural
conservatives
um because if you're a libertarian or
whatever then that's not that's your
you're in a separate camp here there has
been
very little complaint from the right
from cultural conservatives about this
move by Disney
been very little compare religious
conservatives cultural conservatives
seem to have simply accepted that the
left's sexual agenda will be infused
into everything
in fact many of them will probably take
their kids to watch the film
so for all the complaining conservatives
do about Disney for all the complaining
they do about bias in the media notice
what happens
just continue going along with it
especially when it comes to to Disney
because if you ever suggest that perhaps
we should stop letting our kids watch
Disney films most conservatives
Christians will just recoil in horror
I remember when um when Beauty the Beast
was coming out and they're making of
this big deal about the gay element of
the film which ended up being from what
I never even I never watched the movie
but from what I understand from what I
read from sources I trust it ended up
being kind of a essentially a non a
non-event so they made a bigger deal of
it than it actually was but before we
knew that I remember talking I think I
wrote on Facebook and I said yeah are we
at the point where we should consider
not watching Disney movies that anymore
and all of these Christians which I
wouldn't know we can't do that stop
watching Disney what are you talking
about now I grew up with Disney I'm not
gonna stop watching what do you talk
about they were mad at me for even
suggesting it they're more attached to
Disney than they are to their to their
principles and their convictions in fact
it seems that their number one
conviction in life is that I need to be
able to keep watching Disney and all the
other entertainment that I like so we
can complain about
the entertainment industry all we want
but when it comes down to it very few of
us are willing to actually adjust our
entertainment consumption habits very
few of us are willing to do that we will
just keep on ingesting it and we'll let
our kids continue to keep ingesting it
and we act like we have no choice
there's this kind of helpless the sick
helpless attitude that's permeated the
ranks of conservatives and Christians we
act like we haven't like there's no
other option we act like we have to just
float along with the tide because to
resist it's too much effort or something
even the slightest resistance is too
much even to resist it to the extent of
changing the channel or not watching a
certain movie even that's too much
this I think is the crucial difference
between the right and left
one side the right has basically
surrendered the culture and they have
willingly handed their children over to
it
most of what we call the culture war we
say where we're fighting for the culture
most of that stuff is is not relevant
the things that really matter
I think many conservatives have just
given up
especially when it comes to the sexual
stuff
we say the left can do whatever wants
there they can they can meet they can
normalize they can put it in the
mainstream they can do whatever they
want we're not gonna stand in the way
because if we stand in the way of that
then we look like prudes we look like
we're intolerant and we don't want to
deal with those accusations
now listen if you aren't a religious
conservative if you want someone who
believes in the in the or adheres to
judeo-christian morality then um I don't
expect you to have any problem
necessarily with with Disney using their
films as a means to promote
homosexuality although I think even if
you were in that camp and you're a
libertarian or something I would think
maybe you'd still be fed up with this
need to turn every movie into an
opportunity for a leftist sermon but
that aside
I'm speaking now about and to those who
do believe in judeo-christian morality
those of us in that category we have to
ask ourselves at what point do we stop
giving our money to these companies
whose primary mission is to undermine
our morality and to bend - and to
indoctrinate our kids into a morality
that is opposite of our own
it's no good to try and pretend that
well this doesn't matter it's just a
small thing has no effect on anything we
know that isn't true
Hollywood has an immense amount of power
to normalize things
and that is precisely what it's trying
to do and those who advocate for sin
that is that's what you do you normalize
it it's not even a matter of saying of
arguing getting into a moral argument
and saying well here's my arguments for
why this is okay it's just it's just a
matter of making it normal like this is
just what people do it's fine
that's the game that's precisely why
Disney would put a character like that
into a children's movie that is that's
why they're doing
now it used to be that churches were the
normalizing agent in a culture that is
it used to be that churches kind of
decided what was considered normal for a
culture what was considered mainstream
what was considered acceptable that used
to be the case but those days are long
gone and now Hollywood has filled that
void Hollywood is the new church whether
you like it or not
Hollywood has the power to normalize
they're the ones who decide
and if they decide to take something and
start putting it in all their shows and
in all their movies then that's how they
normalize and as long as our kids are
overly exposed to those things they are
inevitably going to begin to
to be indoctrinated into that view
so at what point do we resist that's
where I'll leave you with that question
at what point do we say you know we're
done with this I'm done with Disney I'm
done with all this I'm done with all
this garbage and if that means that my
kids can't heart can't watch hardly any
movies or shows at all then fine because
they'll read a book or they'll go
outside and you know look rip climb a
tree or play hopscotch or something they
can do that
at what point do we make that decision
I think that point is upon us
personal
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed